DefinePropsと同じような感じで
DefineEmitというものもあったりします
今回はそれについて紹介しますね
ちょっとスクリプトを書いて
セットアップとしますね
DefineEmitですね
これもDefinePropsと同じような感じで
特にインポートとかはせずに
いきなりこんな風に関数呼び出しで書くことができます
引数には配列を取りまして
その中にここのコンポーネント内で
Emitをして発生する可能性のあるイベントの名前を
文字列でこんな風に書くことができます
こうすることによって
DefinePropsと同じように
無駄に属性が継承されなくなったりします
正直ですね
このDefineEmitはなくても
こっちのEmitのメインの機能自体は
別に問題なく動きます
なのでこの状態でカウントアップして
リセットボタンを押すとちゃんと100になるんですね
だからこのDefineEmit自体は
そこまで重要な機能ではなかったりします
ただしこんな風に明示的に書くことによって
パッと見でこのコンポーネント内で
どんなイベントが発生するのかが
すぐに分かるようになりますので
基本的には常に書いておくことが
Vue.jsのドキュメントでもお勧めされています
しリンターもですね
こんな風にDefineEmitを書いていなければ
警告を出してくれたりしますので
基本的には必ずEmitを使うときは
DefineEmitもセットで使うと
こういうようにしてください
またこのDefineEmitはもう一つ重要な機能を持っていまして
それが返り値ですね
実はこのDefineEmitの返り値は
このDollarEmitと同じ関数を返してくれますので
例えばこのEmitの処理をスクリプトの中で書きたい場合は
必ずこのDefineEmitの返り値の関数を使う必要があります
なので例えばですけれども
この処理を例えば関数にして
でFuncEmitEmitResetとした上で
その中でですね
Emitの処理を書きたい場合は
この返り値のEmitを使って
リセット100のように書くことで
リセットボタンを押すと100になると
こういう処理を書くことができます
なのでスクリプトからイベントをEmitしたい場合は
必ずこの返り値を使うようにしてください
さては次はEmitをする時のイベントの名前の命名規則についても説明したいと思います
それではまた